operation escargot or operations snail  is what Parisian taxi drivers called  their auntie uber protest drivers  gathered at the city's airports and made  their way to the center at a snail's  pace other motorists had to be patient  at the French capital's busiest time of  day and for once the taxi drivers were  all in agreement today what's important  is the safety of our clients and that  existing legislation be respected and to  strengthen regulation which is nearly  non-existent right now security nucleon  the cab hailing app is already under a  cloud in France the interior ministry is  called for a ban on uber from January  after that there could be hefty fines or  even prison sentences if it offers taxi  rides with private drivers so far  california-based uber has ignored any  legal challenges to its services in  France and with investors willing to  plug the company with billions uber  appears confident it can afford the  legal protection it needs to fight off  the restrictions